let me just tell you a little bit about
mr osborne we call him the lone nut
but here's a man who worked at the cia
base who had his records altered by the
military who defected to russia when he
had no money
he takes a plane when no planes were
available to get into russia he marries
the niece of a high-ranking soviet
official an intelligence officer that's
right and connected to intelligence
slips across the iron curtain without
leaving a trace threatens espionage
while he's there and is not arrested
lives in a community infiltrated by
intelligence agents he's befriended by a
former spy
is seen in close contact with at least
two intelligence agents that's back
after he came back or in the soviet
union after he came back
he makes travel arrangements in the
company of an employee of the cia after
he's gotten or before he went over there
he uses an alias
maybe several he keeps an office in a
building with other agents he eludes
detection by surveillance devices some
way or another he gets a passport when
one should have been denied okay a
second passport also very very quickly
through the state department
and is finally shot down in a room
crowded with police by a former informer
for the nation's chief investigative
agency the fbi
the first in a two-part series on an
update on the kennedy assassination
with gary shaw the author of cover-up
right now on alternative views
[Music]
hey
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
of all of the programs which we do on
alternative views
the two most important subjects that
people like so much and request to see
programs about one cia with john
stockwell and the other programs about
the kennedy assassination particularly
the one we did with gary shaw author of
cover-up oh gosh i guess it was early
1979 well we're real fortunate to have
gary shaw with us to do a couple of
programs
gary is an architect in the fort worth
dallas area
and
unfortunately they only ran off about
three thousand issues of cover-up and
because people are always wanting to buy
it gary shaw is one of the founders and
members of the board of directors of the
assassination archives and research
center in washington dc which is a
research center that has thousands of
books and articles on political
assassinations it has massive collection
of unpublished manuscripts it has a
large collection of photographs and
computer information on various people
that figure in political assassinations
so this is one of the major research
centers in the united states on
political assassinations and gary shaw
for 25 years has been researching the
kennedy assassination and has amassed a
lot of slides films
published materials and today we're
going to run through some of this
material with him on alternative views
we're first going to see a slide
presentation for this program of
alternative use
gary will take us through the history of
the assassination what the warren
commission said and then also
what he thinks really happened
so gary welcome back thank you it's nice
to be back it's a real alternative view
that you'll be seeing here in in a few
minutes with this slide presentation
well you know we've been seeing we've
been getting letters and phone calls
from all around the country where
alternative views have shown and they
all want to see you back again so you're
going to be pleasing a nationwide
audience that's nice to know it's nice
to be back and they also always want to
know about cover-up now it's out of
print right cover-up is out of print i
have approached some publishers about
updating it
bringing it that was 10 years ago now
and bringing it up to date having it
republished and making it available
again to the people hopefully by this
anniversary but we're pushing it
we'll give them a version of cover-up of
your book today
with pictures with slides information
of all sorts okay let's go ahead and
start and see it okay let's go back 25
years
and
see real quickly the president and and
mrs kennedy as they are departing the
texas hotel in fort worth texas this is
on the morning of november 22 1963 and
the president had just made a speech at
a breakfast there for the chamber of
commerce
and he's getting in the limousine they'd
come to texas
to heal party wounds there was a real
split in the democratic party in texas
and
this was a real political
hot spot
on a couple of different people's minds
and so they came as a as a big healing
party to this this split in the in the
party here we see them they they took
off from carswell air force base in fort
worth
flew directly to love field in dallas
which they just got into the air and
right back down they depart
and
open limousine
through the streets of downtown dallas
as you can see in this photograph
governor and mrs conley are in the jump
seat
and
the president mrs kennedy are in the
rear of the automobile the two secret
service men are in the front seat
they had about an hour and a half drive
through the streets of downtown dallas
you'll see that
just to the western end of the downtown
portion of dallas was a beautiful
park-like area
named for
mr joseph dealey caldwelly plaza
in this little area
you can see
the old dallas county courthouse in the
lower right-hand corner just above it is
the dallas criminal court's building and
sheriff's department
the street running straight up and down
is the houston street the one running
vertically across the screen is main
street the motorcade came down main
street to the red courthouse to the
criminal court's building and then turn
directly
up on your screen north in actual
direction and we're heading directly
toward the texas school book depository
which you can see
in the upper portion of this particular
slide elm street is that curving street
that you see come down in front of the
school book depository and disappear
over onto the left hand side of the
screen along with the other two streets
under a railroad overpass
the area
just
to the left of the texas school
depository is
a parking lot railroad yards and just in
front of that is the infamous grassy
know
the place where many of the witnesses
said the assassin shots were actually
fired
and so while we're on this photograph
let me just point out two or three
things this was taken
approximately from the roof of the turn
of the terminal annex building
overlooking dealey plaza we'll talk
about an important witness that was here
the little triangular
place a piece of grass area that you see
between main street and elm street
there were several eyewitnesses in that
area there were several witnesses on the
overpass that we'll talk about and we'll
talk about that area and the railroad
tower in the railroad yards just above
the grassy knoll and to the left of the
texas school book depository but that
just kind of shows you real quickly the
scene
of the president's shooting there in
dallas 25 years ago we might remind the
audience that oswald allegedly shot the
president from the book depository
that's right in the center there that's
correct curious thing
why did they go
and make that
acute angle
low speed turn onto elm street instead
of making the
regular
turn over there on that
on main street seemed like for security
reasons it would have been much better
yes in fact that turn was contrary to
secret service regulations for a turn
and it slowed the limousine down to
approximately 11 to 14 miles an hour
which made a sitting duck out of the
president
and there's been much speculation over
the years about that i think that turn
actually surprised the secret service
because when they were shown the route
this is my understanding of it when they
were shown the route of the motorcade
through downtown dallas when they got to
houston street and they just said and
stemmons freeway is right over here
where it hits stemmons freeway
and be out to market hall and of course
they had been on stems freeway as they
came into dallas from love field
so they really didn't know about that
turn
the turn was made because chief of
police jesse curry was in the lead car
and that's the way you got onto stemmons
freeway is to make that
turn
and i'm sure it was as much or i feel
like it was probably as much a surprise
to that secret service driver
as to anybody
some
people who
look at as a part of conspiracy say that
this was done on purpose to take it by
the book depository and to slow the car
down in violation of the secret service
and that is that is a question that i
think has to be asked i think they knew
that turn had to be made
and they picked
the ideal spot if you've ever been to
dallas
vinda dealey plaza you'll notice
the closeness or the nearness of all of
those the texas school but depository
the grassy knoll and the nearness with
which
everything is compact
a perfect
sitting duck situation for the president
of the united states there well i would
think this route would have had been
chosen
quite some time in advance because
oswald took that job at the book
depository
for some time
well how long he had the job if you take
the position that lee oswald was
involved in the assassination which i
don't necessarily subscribe to then then
then you take that position that there
had to be a lot of prior planning and so
forth or if they want to make him the
patsy that's right and i i my opinion is
is that
yes they
knew they were going to try to kill him
in dallas there was quite a bit of
planning
the execution was almost to perfection
the actual shooting portion of it and i
feel like they had practiced well in
some area even a mock-up
of this
particular area but they knew that that
turn had to be made to get on
and so yes i think there had to be
advanced notice of where the motorcade
was going and how it was going to get
there okay well let's continue with your
slides here this shows the presidential
limousine making that turn off of main
street onto houston going now directly
north directly toward the school book
depository
the dark era you see points to the vice
president lyndon johnson
who is also in the motorcade just a
couple of cars behind the president
which is very very unusual and in fact
against regulations for the vice
president and the president to be this
near together
and so open to assassination
so he was very very
much in a position to see everything
that happened and that raises another
question next slide shows the
nearness of the secret service follow-up
car to the presidential limousine which
is directly in front of it secret
service personnel are on the running
board there's eight of them in that
follow-up car and they're right on the
bumper of the presidential limousine as
it approaches
the texas school of depository one of
the questions you have to ask this is
probably the easiest shot from that
sixth floor school book
window
right there right here at this location
because the president is moving directly
toward that window and is a
perfect shot from that sixth floor yet
he did not take it
this slide shows the president as he
turns directly in front of the school
book depository he's brushing his hair
out of his eyes as he usually did
and it's only a split second later that
the president is his uh
you can see him waving at the crowd this
is from the opposite view
and is actually a slide from the famous
abrahams of fruit as a prudent fan
and the president is waving to the crowd
he's uninjured at this particular time
he's about to disappear behind a road
sign
that comes between zapruder's camera and
the presidential limousine and you'll
see that happen
president was shot at that time
very soon thereafter within the hour
a fellow by the name of lee harvey
oswald was arrested
in nearby oak cliff a suburb of dallas
at the texas theater
why he was arrested is one of those
question marks but let me just tell you
a little bit about mr osborne we call
him the lone nut
but here's a man who worked at the cia
base who had his records altered by the
military who defected to russia when he
had no money
he takes a plane when no planes are
available to get into russia he marries
the niece of a high-ranking soviet
official intelligence officer that's
right and connected to intelligence
slips across the iron curtain without
leaving a trace threatens espionage
while he's there and is not arrested
lives in a community infiltrated by
intelligence agents he's befriended by a
former spy is seen in close contact with
at least two intelligence agents that's
back after he came back or in the soviet
union after he came back
he makes travel arrangements in the
company of an employee of the cia after
he's gotten or before he went over there
he uses an alias
maybe several he keeps an office in a
building with other agents he eludes
detection by surveillance devices some
way or another he gets a passport when
someone should have been denied
okay a second passport also very very
quickly through the state department
and is finally shot down in a room
crowded with police by a former informer
for the nation's chief investigative
agency the fbi
so that's mr oswell ruby was
an fbi informant
well there were other relationships that
uh
that ruby had with the fbi in addition
the cia did he not
he had connections with the fbi in other
words they came to him constantly in
1959.
this was uh
probably when he was doing most of his
work with
with gun running
to the cuban exiles and had contact
in that regard so oswald is just too
visible a figure to really be involved
in such a secret operation as a
political assassin assassination that he
made a point of showing himself to the
public with a lot of newspaper pictures
of him interviews he was involved in his
fair play for cuba organization in new
orleans that got a lot of attention in
that city and that's just not the kind
of person that does a political
assassination unless they're just
completely crazy and i guess that's the
hypothesis that's the hypothesis
that's the reason they say the lone nut
but crazy people don't get around the
soviet union that's right the way he did
and get back and forth between the u.s
and the soviet union in such a peculiar
fashion as one author put it the
fingerprints of intelligence are all
over lee oswald and i think that's
without question at this stage of the
game
of course here you see oswald being
interviewed by
newspaper people at dallas city hall and
here you've seen
being shot by jack ruby
this we call lee oswald a long nut this
is the lone avenger
again we have no connection with oswald
and the cons
in the killing of the president there's
no connection to jack ruby and the
killing of oswald
yet here we find a man who ran a local
nightclub strip joint who had ties to
the underworld was a procurer of women
he dealt in narcotics was an fbi
informant was a friend of over 50
percent of the dallas police force
and what we call a real all-american boy
and to the best of our knowledge at this
stage he was escorted to the kill site
by the assistant chief of police of the
dallas police department at that
particular time and how to be able to
get into that
police building with a gun to
assassinate
as well didn't have any security
whatsoever does this strike you as a
little bit odd he started on friday
night when oswald was arrested
by
coming up to
to the police headquarters
giving the newsmen and the dallas police
officers who were on duty sandwiches
coffee you know anything that he could
do and he knew everybody so he became
highly visible
on the very first day
and he stayed that way through saturday
and through sunday morning when they
made the effort
he had extensive and heavy relationships
with the mafia and was traveling to and
from he came from chicago and
he was heavily involved with the mafia
there and he was known as the mafia man
in dallas very simply and the gun
running was that in support of cia
operations it was not in support of cia
operations but there were cia personnel
or contract agents involved in that
and he was doing that in connection with
a gentleman by the name of tom davis
that would come back
and talk about a little bit
okay so here's another highly suspicious
character this jack ruby he's not just a
man who loved the president and got
revenge as the official story that's the
official story and of course the latest
investigation which was completed in
in late 1970s by the congressional
committee appointed to do so said
very
quickly jack ruby was mafia he was
organized crime
and it's also interesting that both he
and oswald
kept trying to
get a an independent lawyer or somebody
to talk to
and they wouldn't neither was allowed to
do it he wasn't at that time that's
correct
okay of course after oswald was killed
there was no need for a trial for lee
oswal
fortunate
so our new president lyndon johnson from
texas
appoints a blue ribbon commission and
has been pointed out many times by
others
other than myself there was not a friend
of john kennedy on that particular
commission
in fact one of the members is alan
dulles
who was fired by john kennedy after the
bay of pigs fiasco the head of the c.i.a
head of the sea
many many years that's correct one of
the one of the real builders of the
c.i.a
chief justice earl warren of course was
the
the chief
in the of the committee and
one who was
almost
coerced into taking that position he did
not want to do it but lyndon johnson
convinced him that he must do it
and hence we have the name warren
commission
and he was head of the supreme court was
he not he was head of the supreme had a
lot of prestige and was generally
respected so this put a blue ribbon seal
on it
all of these men were were supposedly
highly highly respected
gerald ford was on there of course and
later became president of the united
states after being vice president and
we've learned since then that he was he
played a dual role yeah he was the
fbi's informant for the secret sessions
of the warren commission they even
patted him on the back and gave them one
of the special fbi
out of shades that you
handcuffed your hand i'm sure mr ford
felt
extremely gratified at that
responsibility given him at that time
many people know of the warren report
that's the loan book laying on the floor
and in the foreground
and many people have seen the various
new york times versions or the
associated press versions this is the
government's printing office version
but not many people know that there were
26
supporting or allegedly supporting
volumes to that report in other words
that report was footnoted to these 26
volumes
to show that
that they had done their homework and
that the conclusions reached in the
report were actually backed up by actual
evidence
my friend penn jones who's one of the
real heroes
in this particular case
was fond of saying the problem with the
warren report is that they forgot to
underline in it where they lied to us
because by taking their own 26 volumes
you can
discredit a major portion of the reports
conclusions and findings which is a lot
of what authors did which is what we did
immediately and of course
in addition to that there are volumes
and volumes and volumes in the national
archives and the fbi headquarters and
the various agencies some of which have
still not seen the light of day and
we're still filing freedom of
information
requests and lawsuits to get the
government to release the information on
this case that happened 25 years ago
what really made me the first program we
did with you was that you told us about
a memo
which went to the warrant which the
warrant commission
came out of the staff
gave to the warrant commission in which
they said
at the very start that they were there
to
pin it on oswald that's right the fbi
had already within three days
of the assassination pended on oswald
and a memorandum had been issued by
nicholas kotzenbach the deputy attorney
general
to bill moyers that said all speculation
should be cut off and a report given to
the american people this was on november
25th okay a report given to the the
american people that would satisfy them
that oswald was the assassin and that he
had no confederates this is now called
damage control as well as cover-up i
guess it was cover-up cover-up early on
and now damage controls and euphemism
this is a
photograph
that was famous published on the cover
of life magazine of lee osborne
a very damaging photograph to him
because it shows him holding the rifle
that killed the president on his hip is
the pistol that allegedly shot
the dallas policeman j.d tippet
in his right hand he's holding the two
communist newspapers
and
when shown the picture of course mr mr
oswald says that's my face but that's
not my body
the high select committee on
assassinations had a photographic panel
that said it was not a composite
photograph
but they did not convince anybody
it's still in question
and will remain so more sophisticated
techniques come about with which we can
prove it of course the warren commission
said that this lone nut mr oz will fired
three shots from that sixth floor school
book depository window
all of them
toward the
presidential motorcade the first they
said could have missed may have been the
second shot it missed but at least one
shot struck the president in the back
exited his throat hit connolly went
through him
his body his
right wrist i'll show you a diagram in
just a minute and then a third shot that
struck the president in the head and
killed him this is a reenactment done by
two fbi agents
and you can see the marks that they've
placed
on the fbi agent in the rear which is
representative of the president one way
up in the
upper neck i would call it and then one
in the in the upper back
and then the other man is representing
john conley and you can't see where he
was hit
but
that's the actual
coat worn by
governor conley when he was shot and if
it were a little clearer picture you
could see a chalk mark just below
his right shoulder blade is where he was
struck
this is a diagram that i did just to
kind of give you an indication of what
the single bullet theory is because the
warren commission came up with this
theory that the president and the
governor were both hit by
the same bullet
and actually because of the chronology
or the chronometer given us by the
zapruder film where you can actually see
the effects of the bullet hitting the
people to say that there were more than
one bullet that did this damage is
synonymous with saying that there was
another shooter which they could not do
so here in actuality is what happens the
bullet comes from the sixth floor window
from the left of your screen hits the
president in the back
exits its throat it has to make an
upward trajectory to do that because
it's making a downward trajectory in a
lower portion
of his back
then it comes out just below the tie
knot or just above the tie knot
of his throat
makes a left hand downward i mean a
right hand downward turn and strikes the
governor and just below the right
shoulder blade goes through his chest
blasts out about four inches of his
fifth rib exits just below his right
nipple strikes the main bone of his
right wrist shattering it exits there
and embeds itself in his left leg very
active very active bullet let me show
you a picture of that bullet and and
you can see the bullet that perpetrated
that great feat a miracle there's not a
scratch on it there's not a scratch on
it nor is the nose blooded
and this became the the pristine bullet
or the miracle bullet as we've termed it
over the years because they were never
able to duplicate that
every shot that they fired and i'll show
you some pictures of it in just in just
a minute
every shot that they ever tried to
duplicate that with she either shattered
the bullet or heavily heavily blunted
here you can see
this is the
the wrist of john connolly you can still
see the the white specks are
actually fragments of the bullet that
are in his arm even today
but and to the right is the miracle
bullet the only thing missing from that
bullet that's said to have done that
damage to the wrist is a little nick
that was taken off for spectrographic
analysis otherwise the bullet is is
whole next line shows a cadaver
wrist
shot through the main bone of the
cadaver's wrist and you can see just
that one shot that one bullet blunted
it very very severely
okay not even uh to mention the fact
that the bullet had to change course
several times maybe it was one of those
special cruise missiles
but then pause in midair because i'm
going to show you in just a moment just
how many how much time elapsed between
the time that you can see the president
actually react until you see the the
governor and this is the official
version just one bullet one day oswald
shot three bullets that shot kennedy and
connolly and whatever it's just one
bullet that's that's just the activity
of one bullet they say they say three
shots were fired because they found
three shells okay on the sixth floor
one did this damage that i just
indicated to you and then we'll come
back in a minute and talk about the head
shot which was the second of the three
shots
okay
so that's the way they said it happened
if it didn't happen that way how did it
happen
and i'm a firm believer let's
let's let's look at the evidence let's
see what the evidence says about it
follow it wherever it might lead and see
if we can come up with some alternate
scenario of how the president was shot
in dealey plaza and and i've diagrammed
it this way
i believe it's that this was a group of
very very professional assassins
and they had it very well planned
the first shooting sequence occurred at
the fourth set of road stripes as you
came off of houston street in the dealey
plaza
the president is shot for the second
time at the sixth set of road stripes
and so i'll call that attention to you
i'm just going to call it kill zone a
and kill zone b
and but before they get to that
i'm calling this shot the false assassin
because i think that the planters of
this wanted to call attention to the
sixth floor window where oswal allegedly
was lurking in the shadows to kill the
president of the united states
this shot was fired overhead
never hit anybody
never even came close to hitting anybody
and
completely
hit the sidewalk
bounced
came all the way across dealey plaza
across elm street and and main street
and hit the curb
and actually ricochet either a piece of
the bullet or a piece of the concrete
bounced up and hit a man by the name of
jim tay
what are what are the witnesses to that
or what evidence do we have misery's
donald baker who was a witness said the
bullet hit the pavement near the sign
roy skelton said the bullet hit to the
left of the jfk car he was looking
toward the car so his left would be the
president's right and the cement carried
away from the texas school book
depository
policeman chaney who was riding shotgun
on the motorcycle just to the right of
the president said the first shot missed
mary woodward a newsperson for the
dallas morning news said the first shot
missed
sheriff bill daker
who was riding in the in the lead car
was looking in the rearview mirror and
he said the first shot missed and he
actually said he saw it hit the concrete
and bounce
eugene aldridge
said he was watching television that
afternoon and
a
krld channel 4 cbs affiliate news man
actually
took pictures
of a mark in the sidewalk where
witnesses said a bullet had hit
well he waited until the warren report
came out and there was no mention
whatsoever of that so he began to call
the fbi office
and he had gone down that day and saw
the mark himself not only did he see it
on television
so after he called the fbi and this was
later in 1964
after the commission was out and no
mention was made of it he went down
there and somebody had filled that in
[Music]
very slick
and so
obviously the eyewitnesses say that a
shot hit there this is while the
motorcade is under siege
the first shots have been fired and
the limousine you can see mrs kennedy
reaching over and grabbing her husband's
wrist
and you can see that the
secret servicemen at least on the right
running board the left as you look at
the picture are looking backwards the
shot came from the rear or hit somewhere
to the rear it would be just to the left
of that
that that that shot would have hit the
sidewalk
here is a picture taken
of that mark on the sidewalk
and it
does not exist today because a
dallas morning news brave photogra i
mean a newspaperman
actually drilled that out
and took it and had it analyzed
unfortunately all metallic
substance had been scraped out of it but
they could tell that there had been a
porous
filler placed in it at one time or
another
here you can see the arrow points to a
man and i hope you can see it on the
television screen a man standing over
there this is a bystander by the name of
jim [ __ ] who was the only other person
besides mr kennedy and mr conley who was
wounded and he was wounded slightly on
the cheek by either a fragment of the
bullet as i said
or
by a piece of concrete that flew off of
the curb
here's a picture of where that fragment
of the bullet or the bullet hit the curb
that's a man's hand that's shadowing
that's so that the photograph can be
taken
but that's a point in in line
with the trajectory of a bullet that was
totally
shot
beyond the motorcade and not even an
attempt was made
to hit the motorcade with that and yet
it caused attention to that window
because the people in the latter part of
the motorcade that are driving directly
toward the school book depository see
the gun barrel sticking out of the
window
and
the one of them says
one of them that the after the last shot
is fired at the motorcade this same
individual seems to lean out the window
as if to admire his handiwork
and to draw attention and to draw
attention to that window okay this is
the kill zone a i was talking about
earlier and
we'll just take the president's wounds i
call this gunman number one and gunman
number two that's a triangulation of
gunfire very strategically located and
by the way that's a very short distance
from
point one to point a and from point two
to point a and i'll come back and show
you some photographic evidence of a man
in that position at the time of the
shots in just a minute let's see point
one is that on top on top of the school
book depository okay okay
here's the president as he comes from
out from behind that sign that
took his view from zapruder's family you
can see that he's reacting to a shot
and it's probably that back shot because
when the
fbi looked at the wound they estimated
engaged that wound to have entered the
president's back at a 45 to 60 degree
angle
the osw window could have only been
20 degrees or so
so the only point that would be anywhere
near a 45 to 60 degree angle would be
move down to the western end of the
school of depository and go on the roof
and then you can get that kind of a
trajectory
okay
this is the warren commission's version
of how that bullet went into the
president's back and exited his throat
the artist who painted this notice it's
not a photograph the artist who painted
this
actually
never saw the wounds
he was told what to paint
okay so you can see that a wound in the
back has moved
up into a wound in the neck
and is exiting more in line with what
would be consistent with going on and
hitting governor conley this is the
autopsy sheet
it's verified it has the signature of
george berkeley the president's
physician who was there at the time and
if you look at the back view you can see
that the wound in the back
is way down below the collar
that's consistent
here is again an artist the same artist
did this see how far he placed the
bullet up
but yet if you take the president's coat
where the wound
shows in his coat and in his shirt
the dark mark when i placed on the
drawing myself
is the is where the location of the of
the in shoot into the president's body
would be
this is the president's coat
the
entrance of the bullet was five and
three-eighths inches down from the
collar
this is his shirt it was five the hole
in his shirt was five and three quarter
inches so you can see how everything is
consistent with a back one not an upper
neck wound
the next slide shows a skeleton
and
the president's chief physician george
berkeley said
that the wound in his back
occurred at the third thoracic vertebra
well the third thoracic vertebra is in
the exact location as shown
by the coat by the shirt
and by
even the
secret service personnel who were
following the president who said they
saw the president get hit in the back
not in the neck gary this might be the
point to discuss kennedy's body what
happened to the corpse afterwards
obviously this theory could be confirmed
if there was a close examination of the
body of kennedy after the murder what
actually happened and what is the story
the later story about kennedy's body
okay that's a good a
friend of mine an author by the name of
david lifton wrote a great book called
best evidence
and titled that because
in a
murder case the best evidence of how the
crime was committed is the body
a correct autopsy will show
number of shots direction of shots type
of bullets everything that you need to
know about
the the case is contained right there
the president's body was forcibly taken
by from the dallas authorities
and flown to bethesda maryland to a
naval hospital there
and an autopsy was performed
when the i taught when the body arrived
there for
autopsy
something had happened the doctors at
parkland
left
a slight one inch to one and a quarter
inch incision for a tracheotomy over
this wound that they called a wound of
entrance every one of them called it
wound of entrance the nurses this is the
hospital that all trauma victims all gun
victims come to they know
a wound of penetration or an entrance
wound from an exit wound so he just
barely made an incision so that he can
insert the trach
they said the back of his head was
out and brains was the president's
brains were falling out on the table
but this wound when it arrived at
bethesda had become a three and a
quarter inch gaping gash
with all
evidence
of the penetration wound obliterated in
other words none of the dark
flesh that surrounded it it had all been
cut off and even the slides of any
tissue that was taken from that has
disappeared has disappeared from the
evidence
contained within the national archives
an entrance room will be quite small and
the exit will be a large hole that's
right the entrance wound will actually
be smaller than the projectile because
of the pliability and the elasticity of
the skin and it will go through and then
the skin will come back where it exits
it's the the bullet is normally expanded
or turned and it's coming out at an odd
angle or something of that nature and it
tears the skin and makes a much larger
opening normally than the uh than a
wounded venture so this means that
somebody monkeyed with a body
in transit that's great
has to have happened because even the
president's brain
was not in the cranium
and
surgery had been performed in this area
none of the dallas doctors
had done any surgery to the president's
head and was there any testimony that
there was a wound in the back or other
parts of his wound in the back actually
the
an fbi report says that the doctor
probed it with his little finger
to the first knuckle
and that's as far as he could go
he said this wound does not continue any
further
and then someone of a higher authority
told him do not probe that wound
so that wound was never probe we're left
to guess as to what happened to it
we can't guess too much because
if it continued downward at that angle
it would have gone into his lungs
there's evidence that he did have a
wound of the lungs because when he came
to parkland hospital there was bubbly
blood coming from this wound in his
throat which indicates that there had
been damage done to to the lungs
but the big the big blow the one that
really killed him was the
blow to the was the shot to the head
right that blew his top of his head off
that's possible but this could have been
a killing wound
the wounded entrance here
i think that probably the reason that
you have the three and a quarter inch
gaping gash when it arrives there is
that a missile had to have been
removed from that because there was no
exit
of that or the one in the back
and
when martin luther king was assassinated
he received a simulator shot although it
went through his jaw first but it went
through and it lodged at the brain stem
area back here which is a life or death
matter you separate that
brain stem from your spinal
function there and you're immediately
dead and that could have happened to
to the president very easily so what are
the conclusions from this the the
conclusions are that there were two fbi
agents who signed a receipt for a
missile
taken from the president's body at the
time of the autopsy a missile now
that's that's not fragmented
well a missile is a bullet okay okay
they call it a missile if it's a
fragment they call it a fragment of the
missile or a fragment of a bullet and
the bullet is the so-called perfect
bullet what we don't know is it
disappears it disappears when it's never
heard of again okay and it's never been
satisfactory explained where it came
from we don't know because the
the magic bullet had already been found
on a hospital stretcher at parkland
hospital and turned over to authorities
this bullet was removed at bethesda
into the autopsy and disappeared though
we do have the documents fortunately
that
that talk about it so the warren
commission report says that a single
bullet and a single wound killed kennedy
and that they have the bullet the
so-called magic bullet and you're
suggesting that it must have been more
than one bullet and more in one than one
wound
okay and did they also come from
different angles and we will get into
protection to get into that with this
very next shot because the next slide
shows again the the one to the left i
want you to pay particular attention to
the era going in is where the warren
commission said the blood the third
thoracic vertebra is that is the other
area arrow and is where the bullet went
in and again notice the verification by
dr berkley on that on that sheet here
are the two documents that i was just
telling you about they very definitely
stipulate that a missile was removed
from the president's body at the autopsy
at bethesda we have not seen them today
the bullet possibly came from the roof
because that's where the angle the
trajectory would take it this is a
amateur
film taken right after the assassination
of a rifle that
shows up we don't know what kind of
rifle don't know that it had anything to
do with it but the the person who was
taken with them thought that these
officers and detectives had gathered
around that for a reason
and and dubbed it on their own film the
assassin's rifle and this is not oswald
this is not oswald's rifle nor does it
come anywhere close to looking like it
and there we do know
that
there was rumored to have been a rifle
found on the roof of the texas school
book depository
i want to go and talk about that bullet
that was almost simultaneous
okay to the bullet in the back
and if you go back to that picture i
showed of killzone a
you'll notice i had one assassin on the
grassy knoll and one on the roof i want
to talk quickly about that bullet that
is the wound of entrance here as opposed
to the back one that we were talking
about a while ago
because
it was so simultaneous and i think this
was directed by someone on site
either by radio or by by signal
and when it occurred
this this particular bullet of entrance
was the one who almost paralyzed him and
possibly killed him but j lee rankin
said it seems quite apparent now and
this was in 1964 after the warren
commission had met in secret session
they were meeting in secrecy it seems
quite apparent now since we have the
picture of where the bullet entered
below the place
where the picture
shows
the bullet came out in the neck band of
the shirt in front
here we are two months
after hoover has issued his report of
the loan assassin
and they're already still talking about
this wound in the back being below the
wound in the front which creates a
trajectory
that would miss governor connolly
so he's saying that hey we need to do
some more study on this even in january
of 1964.
okay simultaneous with the preceding
shot
here at zapruder frame is
228
you can see
the president clutching at his throat
it's real important to note that all the
doctors and all the nurses
said that that was a wound of entrance
but i think that it's more important to
see how
they tried to cover up that fact in a
january 1964
transcript that came from the warren
commission secret
sessions john mccloy who was a member
says i think we ought to take a look at
the grounds and somebody ought to do it
and get the picture of this ankle to see
if it is humanly possible for him to
have been hit in the front
from a shot fired from that window maybe
it is
of course we know it's not unless they
could bank a shot
and then life magazine also kind of
contribute to that a lot of people don't
know this but
on december the 6th they published their
memorial edition of
kennedy's death and in that they had
some nagging rumors and one of them was
how the president was hit in the front
and the throat
from that window which was in back of
him they said it's real easy we have the
supruder film now
and it shows the president turning
around in his seat exposing his throat
to that window oh of course we know that
didn't happen no this pruder film
doesn't show that at all at all
unfortunately the the author or the
writer of that particular article died
of cancer in 1965 so we could not go ask
him
who directed him to write that or what
was his reasons for writing that well
life magazine also was one that doctored
up that snapshot of oswald with hope
with him holding all the rifles they
contributed heavily to the framing of
lee harvey oswald in this
okay next slide just quickly shows how
the people reacted and shows that there
were shots from the president's right
front because these witnesses you see
laying on the ground
said the shots came directly over my
head
toward the president
from the grassy knoll and they hit they
hit the dirt
the lady in the
red coat is miss gene hill she
saw a man in dark clothing across the
street
and saw him run from the scene
and attempted to to follow him got over
there and was stopped
by a man who served who showed her
secret service identification
our official identification let's put it
that way and told us she could go no
further
here is a slide taken almost
simultaneous with the first shot
you can see the error points to the head
of president kennedy if
i want you to pay close attention to the
little low wall that juts out from the
stemmons freeway sign the little white
wall on the left on the left jump just
out there i'm going to blow it up with
this next slide
there you can see above
the low
white wall there on the grassy knoll
a man
it's been definitely identified by
analysts to be a man wearing a dark
clothing dark hats you can see his
facial features
and the house select committee even went
so far as to say that there was
something
a long object protruding from this
person at a 45 degree angle of course
they could not determine it's my opinion
that that's where the shot was fired
from and he quickly disappeared a second
photographer almost at the same instance
that that previous photograph was taken
shows the same person behind the little
low wall just to the left of the
stemmons freeway sign
this shows the same little low wall
within
six seconds after the
photograph you just saw a while ago and
the presidential motorcade has not even
cleared the underpass but i'll blow up
again the little white wall and you can
see that the person has completely
disappeared
and he's gone from the scene
so
a shot from the front you can see how
the police ran over there one of the
motorcycle patrolmen jumped off and just
dumped his motorcycle and ran up there
pursuing
the person that he shot
that he thought fired the shots and over
50 eye and ear witness
in daly plaza said the shots were fired
from that grassy knoll area and the
zapruder film clearly shows kennedy
getting hit on the in the forehead by a
shot from the front which kicks his head
back but the warren commission
absolutely ignored all all of that
that's correct that's the next two shots
this is the final two shots that hit the
president this is in kill zone b
are the six that are road stripes and
comes from the
southwesterly sixth floor window of the
school book depository and from the
picket fence just above the grassy knoll
to the left that's number three and
number four okay the the president is
shown here just before he's he's hit
with the fatal head shots you can see
the position of his head you'll see how
the
they doctored that particular photograph
in just a
there is the explosion
the the
great intensity of the bullets that
struck the president's head that's
pieces of his brains
flying through the air
you can see the explosive nature of what
happened that's the president's
head and it's just opened up on the
right hand side this i believe was from
the shot from the rear
and the school book depository now
eyewitnesses saw
a gunman
standing back in the shadows in that
southwestern
not the sniper's nest window but the one
on the far westerly end of that same
floor
as the podium as the motorcade arrived
he was standing back in the shadows
cradling a rifle
so this shot i believe came from that
area was a perfect shot and
more of a glancing blow to the side of
the president's head that opened it up
and you can see how open it is
here those two slides together done in
sequence you can see the
great movement of the president
backwards as the second shot overrides
the first shot and hits him as the
priest said and as
the
president's chief aide said in the right
temple and blasted out the rear portion
of his head
look at the distortion of the artist
persian
the president's head is never in that
position
but
to get their wounds like they needed
them they put the president's chin down
on his chest
and drew this version of the entrance
and exit wound when in actuality
he did lose that portion of the side of
his head but he also lost a big portion
of the occipital region and a piece of
the occipital bone was found on the
southern
side of elm street
past the curve and in the rearward
position from where the president was
actually hit
remember there were motorcycles a
motorcycle patrolmen riding to the
president's left rear
they were struck with brain tissue with
such force they said they thought they
themselves had been hit
and then that's malcolm killed up the
president's aid pointing he sent the
president he's at a press conference and
he said the president was hitting the
right temple
this lady in the foreground took a very
very important
motion picture
that has never seen the light of day i
i've interviewed her her film was
confiscated by people who identified
themselves as either secret service or
fbi
and
that film would be very important
because it would show not only the texas
school book depository
but also all of the grassy knoll at the
time of the shooting
the final shot
in the scenario
was a crucial
shot also because it planted evidence
pointed the finger to that assassin's
window and the assassin's lair and as
i've already stated the people said that
the man who fired the shot seemed to
have lingered and hung out the wind as
if to call attention to himself
but the bullet actually struck the
ground and would have passed over the
motorcade's head by about 12 to 15 feet
and it struck near a manhole cover it
was seen by eyewitnesses photographed by
newsmen but
what happened was that the
the
ground was plowed up
it was called attention to
and a man who was identified by police
chief jesse curry as an fbi agent came
over and reached down into the ground
and you can see that it's
there's something in the grass i know he
wasn't a rock collector
but he picks up something in the grass
stands up and you can see he has his
hand closed
and then he puts it into his pocket and
that particular bullet is never heard or
seen from
again
very important evidence
again
destroyed
or hidden to this day what are your
conclusions from the
information you've presented the
conclusions are real simple
that there were multiple shooters
in dele plaza and multiple shooters
means conspiracy
more than one
where it leads to from there
is
i think probably more important and of
more concern to us as citizens of the
united states
because it was within the hands of the
united states government
that this evidence
was covered up
because we have
testimonies altered
we have evidence mutilated and distorted
obscured destroyed
everything that could be done to
evidence
is done in this particular case
and so
someone high up in our federal
government made the decision to cover up
the true facts about the death of the
president but it took considerable
coordination and participation among a
lot of people to do this to execute it
to plan it execute it and then to cover
it up right
and i guess that'll be the topic of our
next program where we'll go through the
theories of what actually happened in
the assassination of john f kennedy you
can give your analysis of the facts what
you think happened we can discuss some
of the other theories then we can
discuss some of the new evidence and new
controversies that have arisen
concerning the kennedy assassination in
recent years and what this means for us
as a democracy why we shouldn't forget
this event great i look forward to it
be sure to watch the next alternative
views for the second in this two-part
series on an update on the kennedy
assassination
if you'd like to contact gary shaw
here's here's the dress
p.o box 722
cleburne texas 76031
he of course is the author of cover-up
also gary shaw is a co-founder and
member of the board of directors
of the assassination archives and
research center in washington d.c
the aarc was established as a
long-needed centrally located permanent
center for the study of assassinations
particularly helpful to scholars
and this is all assassinations national
and international historic and current
the research material includes several
thousand books and articles
a massive central
research file
unpublished manuscripts photographs
tapes
a computer index of fifteen thousand
names in events
and the various fbi and cia documents
which are relevant to assassinations
particularly those from the house select
committee on assassinations
there are also fbi documents relating to
the robert kennedy murder and the
attempt of the life of george wallace
we'd like to thank our
crew for these two programs director
brian lynch our camera people ronnie
mack johanna mccallick and beverly
garrett and our audio man was jack
hopper
alternative views is a production of the
alternative information network
p o box 7279 austin texas 78713
that's another address you can write
down so you can write to us as well as
gary shaw
bye
in the 1960s
the cia
using them as
is sort of the
the real planning
group
had within their group a program they
called the zr rifle program that was the
kryptonium for their assassination
apparatus
okay
out of this zr rifle program the the
kryptonym for its principal agent
was qj win
q j will q j win
okay
and of course this cr rifle program
began
to be used with respect to cuba in
1961
and in doing so that's when they first
became
involved with organized crime
this qj win plays an important role in
the release
on
very shortly after this assassination of
a man by the name of tom davis released
released from custody of the of the
police over in algeria he was arrested
and as a gun running activities he was
released with the on on the behest or
with the help of qj wind
what makes this intriguing is that tom
davis told a well-respected reporter in
dallas
that he was using the name of oswal
and in his gun running activities to the
cuban exiles that he was connected to
the cuban exiles but that he was running
these guns with a man by the name of
jack ruby
who was the killer of lee harvey oswald
which as we now know
will be out a shot of a doubt that jack
ruby connects to organized crime
directly what mr meretz did best among
other things
was smuggle heroin into the united
states
he was a killer became a member of the
french secret service and that's
the equivalent of our cia stack
and
in his connections with that
organization
began a drug operation into this country
he in my opinion was a is a good suspect
for the director of the
assassination and could possibly be qj
win who was a european
the second in our two-part series on an
update on the kennedy assassination with
the author of cover-up
we'll provide recent information
uncovered by the freedom of information
act
by interviews with various people and
congressional sources right now
[Music]
ah
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we're back again with gary shaw author
of cover up
an architect in the dallas fort worth
area cover-up is one of those books an
incredible book which tells the truth
about the kennedy assassination
our last program we went into great
detail to show that it was impossible
for one person lee harvey oswell or
anybody to have killed john f kennedy
because there were more than one shot
fired
well
on our program this week we're going to
do some speculation about what this
means for the country we're going to
talk about some of the new evidence that
has come up since the last program we
did with with gary back in 1979
and some surprise connections with us
too
what has happened since 79 there have
been congressional investigations and
your investigations have been going on
what's some of the highlights
well the house select committee on
assassinations of course came out with
their conclusion that there was a
probable conspiracy which was a real
winner
for us
we fought long and hard for that and had
actually assisted that committee
in
every way that we could to see that they
reached
that conclusion unfortunately they
didn't go far enough they did say that
the justice department should pursue
several areas
which they have not done even to this
date
the chief counsel for that committee
said that it was a historical fact as
far as he was concerned the mob killed
john kennedy
now i don't know as i totally agree i
agree that the mob
was heavily involved and
probably paid a big portion of the money
and used their personnel to do it
but there were others i think in
involved in it they didn't say anything
about the fbi or the cia they said that
the warren commission as a whole and the
investigative bodies that was used by
the warren commission all was flawed
so there was a real put down by this new
committee of the original warren
commission and its report and its
findings and conclusions
and so that was important to us if we're
going to get the truth
out to the american people that was a
big step or a big hurdle unfortunately
the major news media
said ho hum to it
and therefore the majority of the
american people don't even know that
even though they still believe
today
that at least about 85 to 90 percent of
the american people believe that oswald
did not act alone
they've they've never been given any
evidence on prime time national
television
to show them why they believe that and
there's plenty as you've seen last week
and we'll talk about this week gary
let's start up off with this concept of
the cover-up this was the title of your
book
who did the cover-up of the kennedy
assassination and why you've indicated
that the warren commission report was
part of this but who would want to cover
up the truth about the kennedy
assassination well i asked that question
many times because when you start asking
that you
you start looking at men like earl juan
and alan dulles and gerald ford and
j edgar hoover and
richard helms who was director of
the central intelligence agent agency at
that time
and you just go on and on and it's
mind-boggling to know
that uh
hey there was
something amiss here that there was a
cover-up and did these men do it
and
i don't even try to answer that question
any longer all i can say without a
shadow of a doubt is that there was a
cover-up
and we can point to it specifically and
in particular instances
that changed the real
meaning of the president's death
and i'm not going to sit here and say
president johnson
did it and caused it to be done i don't
think we could do that
i think you've got to come back
around and find out who did it
you know
get somebody who we know covered up or
altered testimony and say why did you
alter this testimony why did you do this
who told you to do it who was your
superior that caused this to happen
and then go right on up the ladder and i
think eventually we'd get to the truth
the incredible part about it to me is
not only these various government
agencies were involved in the cover-up
but also the regular mass media life
magazine
the networks and even as late as when
was that dan rather cover-up thing about
what about 10 years ago 10 years ago
where they came out and they looked at
all the evidence we're going to make
sure we do everything right and they
came to the conclusion that oswald was
the lone assassin and now recently when
walter cronkite was wanting to do a
complete investigation and documentary
on the kennedy assassination cbs turned
him down even uncle walter
but you remember that uncle walter was
the one that was interviewing linda
johnson
when lyndon johnson made the comment
that we were running a quote a damned
murder incorporated in the caribbean
in the early 1960s do you remember that
and cbs cut that completely out and it
was years before we knew what was cut
out we just knew that something was cut
and
so
the media did participate in the
cover-up now cd jackson is a long time
oss and cia he's had his name
yes uh he was he was the head of time
life at that time very big person in the
total american power structure she was a
big person in the organizations like the
trilateral commission the bilderbergers
the council
[Music]
unfortunately he died soon after that
he he was the one responsible for buying
this brutal film
printing a few frames of it in life
magazine and then locking it up because
he didn't think the american people
ought to see it
i take the opposite view if the american
people had seen that film on friday
night november the 22nd
1963 they'd have never bought
the lone assassin single bullet theory
well let's take a look at that
remarkable and revealing film right now
this is the famous abraham supruder film
of the kennedy assassination
the president is
now
hit in the back and then while he's
behind the sign he's hit in the throat
from the front he's now grasping at his
throat and trying to talk to his wife
and the fatal head shot
this is a blow up of that head shot
the president is hit now he's trying to
talk to his wife
and he receives the fatal head shot
the president's reaction to the head
shot can be seen more clearly with these
enlargements
notice that as the president is struck
by the fatal head shot his body is
driven violently backwards
let's indeed go into some of these
theories of who actually did the kennedy
assassination beginning with your theory
at the end of cover-up your book that
was published on the kennedy
assassination you ran through all the
possible suspects and then reached some
conclusions as to what might have
happened you want to recap that for us
and then we can take off from that okay
what i did in 1976 and i've changed a
little since then and of course i think
a person that doesn't change
as new evidence comes to light is you
know
you better change
but i look three things any crime
motive means an opportunity
john kennedy without a doubt had managed
to alienate every
every major force in the country whether
it be the right wing or or the military
or the cia
organized crime his brother bobby was
going after organized crime like no one
had ever done before
and
everybody it seemed like or every
special interest group he had managed to
alienate so there were a lot of people
the the all
people here in texas the extreme right
wing here in texas hated him the cubans
the cuban exiles pigs
because of that and so
he had enemies
so there was a lot of motive to his
death
each one of these groups had the means
you know
and each one of them had the opportunity
well they also said bobby kennedy they
were saying that they were thinking
about shutting down the cia because of
the
bad information that they received and
the bad guidance right concerning they
well he made a pig so that's another
connection robert and john both
alienated the military leaders because
they wanted to go blow cuba off the face
of the earth when the missile crisis was
going on
and so they had a lot of enemies and
each one of them had motive means and
opportunity yeah you understand
but the big thing that i pointed out in
1976 is
not all of those groups had the ability
or the power to cover up the true facts
surrounding the assassination
and so that's what i tried to look at
and i said in 1976 that
to cover up
the facts surrounding the assassination
was proper suspicion of guilt
and so i pointed a strong finger after
examining the motives and the means of
all of these groups i appointed a strong
finger and i think you know still could
toward the military industrial
intelligence complex that that had
evolved and that president eisenhower
had warned about
before he left office
and
i've changed somewhat since then just
simply because some of the things that
we know now has has caused me to change
that to me would involve too many people
too many people that i think are
honorable people
not everybody in the cia is a bad guy
not everybody in the fbi is band most of
them are are american citizens of
of good mind and good quality and good
moral values and and so forth
so i had to look at it
as the years went by from from another
standpoint because the people kept
asking me boy that's a huge conspiracy
somebody's going to crack and talk
so
i finally came
around to
as we learned about the strange marriage
between
the executive branch and organized crime
through a mistress
through assassination apparatus pointed
toward fidel castro in cuba that was
okayed by the kennedys
operated by the cia operated by the
c.i.a
and using cuban exiles because they
wanted to get cuba back for many reasons
cuba the organized crime wanted it back
because as their las vegas off the coast
of florida
you know that's a money making
you know that was their
drug
jumping off place into the united states
and
america the united states wanted cuba
they didn't want
reds
right there 90 miles off the coast
and so there was a strange marriage
between this cia personnel who were
training the cuban exiles and by the way
they trained them well in sabotage
assassination and smuggling
the cubans are still using that
even today you know
and so you have that marriage that
if and this is purely speculation but i
don't mind speculation if it's
good speculation
let's just take a scenario that they put
together an assassination team to go
after castro well we know they did this
has been
and they failed
our government says that they failed
eight times mr castro says about 24
times
probably somewhere in between that's
true but probably closer to mr castro's
estimate
but
if let's say they turn these same
assassins
or say they turn for whatever reason
more money
because they
hated what mr kennedy was doing they if
they were cuban exiles or
partially cuban exiles they hated it
because kennedy had now turned his back
on his promise of a free cuba
organized crime
had felt betrayed because here they were
working together and now suddenly
they're not you don't do the mafia that
way
you know you jump in bed with them and
you go along with them and everything's
fine but if you cross them uh they'll
write you a letter
and uh it kind of blows up and blows up
and
let's say that this same group
ended up shooting the president of the
united states in dallas in fact on the
day that it happened
robert kennedy picked up the phone and
called one of the cuban exiles
and said
one of your guys
kill the president
this was in the washington post and this
came out just about probably five or six
years ago
okay so here's bobby kennedy saying
you know
what
i have a tendency to believe happened
that there was some cuban exiles
involved
and they were trained in assassination
why not use them
and they wanted revenge because their
brothers their friends their their
compatriots and and the invasion of at
the bay and pigs were slaughtered they
think they
sabotaged the bay of pigs that the
eisenhower administration had promised
these cuban exiles that the united
states would invade cuba or would at
least organize an invasion of cubans
to overthrow castro and kennedy was
unenthusiastic about it and didn't give
them what they consider adequate support
so they were outraged they were outraged
and the one thing that he did is that
they were promised an umbrella of air
support
you don't invade
without that air support and that's what
kennedy called off
right at the last minute and left them
vulnerable
at the invasion and allowed them to be
slaughtered
that was the key word with the cuban
exiles by the way and we may talk about
this if you if you want to and that's
this umbrella of air support
every time they would turn they would
talk about the invasion of the bay of
pigs they would talk about we're going
to have an umbrella of air support
that will carry us in
and and make ready for this invasion of
course there were a lot of flaws in the
sea i the cia estimated that the
people would uprise against castro and
there would be easy pickens but as we
know this didn't happen so they didn't
even without the
even if they had had the air umbrella
it's still been highly questionable
whether they've been that's right well
the key was though is that if they could
make the invasion work and get into the
mountains just like castro did then
that's when the people
would
they would begin to sway people to come
in their directions
and they never got with that they were
never able to get that little guerrilla
group like castro had so we don't know
whether it would have worked or not
right but they of course thought that it
would yes well there was also another
very important situation regarding cuba
and kennedy and that is i understand
that kennedy was having secret
indirect talks through the swiss embassy
or somebody with castro
french embassy to try to normalize
relations with with castro and of course
the cia would have known about this and
so this they would have fed this to
their buddies and
well there have been some very strange
things that have happened that popped up
in the past oh eight years
like you were showing me some guy can
actually confess to being part of the
assassination team
that's something we could download
most most of your viewers will be
familiar with the john
judge john wood case in san antonio a
federal judge who was assassinated
in 1979
and that a man by the name of charles
harrelson
was arrested tried convicted and
sentenced to life in prison for
that assassination and that's what it
was
but what most people don't know is that
when he was arrested mr harrelson
actually confessed
and this is a
a march 20th
1981 dallas morning news article
several officers heard the confession of
charles harrelson as he confessed to
killing president john kennedy
and this is in just about two three
little surprises buried in the bottom in
the middle of the uh report right and
they never even never got national
coverage of a major neighborhood so was
he involved with organized crime did
this guy yes and of course we we're
always interested in fact we were
interested in it as soon as he killed
john wood simply because of his
appearance
because
actually on the day of the assassination
three men were taken into custody
hiding over beyond the grassy knoll in a
boxcar open boxcar
they were paraded across
elm street in front of the school book
depository and about six photographs
were taken of them these are the famous
three tracks the famous three tramps and
taken into the sheriff's headquarters
nothing was ever said about them there
is no record of their arrest
who they are without pictures
we've got pictures but we never knew who
they were and the pictures and what and
the pictures of what are what's
fascinating
because
these will be bad bad photographs but
here is a picture of one of the tramps
along with the
mugshot of charles harrelson you can see
the strong facial resemblance
here
here's another photograph at a different
angle of the
of the tall
uh tallest of the three tramps
and also a different view of a
photograph of charles harrelson
and we've got that
so much
the same [ __ ] the same tall [ __ ]
but a different view of charles
harrelson
not only do the photographs look like
not only has he confessed but he also
was connected to all the right people he
was he was a friend of the of the best
friend of jack ruby knew jack ruby
he
was familiar with dallas and organized
all the organized crime figures in
dallas he
also was involved with gun running
during the bay of pigs so he was
familiar with cuban exiles and some of
cia personnel he had he had all the
right connections and
these photographs as bad as they were
were shown to
some
forensic
[Music]
pathologists to study facial features
okay and testify in courtrooms
about whether this photograph
if it's aged 10 years
would look like this photograph and
their findings on three of these these
photographs were that there was a 90 to
95 percent probability
that charles harrelson and this tallest
of the three tramps were one in the same
so this would give credence to his
confession very much so let's go back
for just a minute this organized crime
connection you pointed out that
organized crime was very angry
because
they lost cuba they had big prostitution
gambling all kinds of drug organizations
that were operating in cuba after the
cuban revolution of course they were put
out of business so they would be in
favor of the overthrow of castro
and therefore would be angry at the
failure of the bay of pigs plus robert
kennedy is attorney attorney general
went after organized crime and they
thought they had an understanding with
the kennedys that they would leave the
kennedys alone and cooperate in certain
ways if the kennedys didn't come after
them and bobby kennedy came after him so
they would think that they were betrayed
and in terms of their primitive ethic
that therefore they could get revenge
well there's evidence that
that organized crime got them the
illinois vote you know how important
they are stealing the election through
the daily machine in chicago that's
right
um
so
we also know that sam giancana was out
of chicago
and he had a mistress
most of some of your viewers probably
are familiar with that came out just
this this year that a lady by the name
of judith ecksner was a mistress of sam
genkana head of the chicago mafia and
also head of
this assassination
attempts on fidel castro organized by
our cia
and that jack kennedy had a relationship
with this same judith exner and she
tested her that she
yes they were lovers
mistress and that she
actually became a courier between the
president of the united states and sam
genkana during the period that she was
seeing him in and out of the white house
there's another mistress involved here i
saw in a liberty lobby or a spotlight
article a few years ago where there was
an investigation or something maybe you
read about that too about marita lorenz
who had been
one of the favorites of fidel castro and
she had testified
in court that she had participated in a
two-car caravan
a couple days before the assassination
that went to dallas
this caravan had
rifles had firearms one of the people
one of the passengers was lee harvey
ours allswah oswald
and when they got to dallas they were
paid off by e howard hunt
who also took the arms now is this
verifiable or is it anything you've
heard about i've heard about it and read
about it and there's no way you can
verify something like this except to say
that e howard hunt
goes way way back to the origin of the
bay of pigs under richard nixon richard
nixon is the one that
originally started this
movement to invade cuba using the cuban
exiles and using even howard hunt and
bernard balker
and
vergidio gonzalez and all of these are
martinez and all of these
people that later end up james mccart
end up as the watergate burglars
two of the people in this caravan with
her were also turned up everywhere you
look you see again you see howard hunt
in fact when
charles bremmer
arthur bremmer
shot
george george wallace
the first person ordered to bremer's
apartment was e howard hunt
so there's another major hypothesis here
that
part of the theory of some people was
that
after the kennedy assassination it would
be blamed on fidel castro that oswald
was a member of this fair play for cuba
committee or at least there were
pictures of him associated with this
group plus his connections with the
soviet union that you outlined in the
first program that he had defected to
the soviet union that he'd married the
daughter of an intelligence agent etc so
they were building therefore a scenario
where they could blame it on fidel
castro the assassination of john f
kennedy and could use that as a pretext
for the invasion of cuba which would of
course satisfy both the mob plus these
right-wing cubans and other right-wing
groups
in the united states so this is also
part of at least a scenario as to what
was going on i think i think a very
important part of the scenario that was
going on they they wanted
the patsy they wanted the finger pointed
to
to fidel castro so that there would be
an uprising against it
let's show the people your conception of
the organizational structure of the cia
and the
mafia and the relationships and how this
was set up
in the 1960s
the cia
using them as
is sort of the
the real planning
group
had within their group a program they
called the zr rifle program that was the
kryptonium for their assassination
apparatus
okay
out of this zr rifle program the the
kryptonym for its principal agent
was qj win
q j q j win
okay
and of course this cr rifle program
began
to be used with respect to cuba and
and 61
and in doing so that's when they first
became
involved with organized crime this sam
ginkana johnny roselli
both who died strange and untimely
deaths before they could give testimony
to a senate
committee
and this organized crime group
also were utilizing the cuban exiles
and also out of this cr rifle program
the the man chiefly responsible
for it
was a man by the name of william harvey
he was the coordinator for the for the
cia for the cr rifle program through the
cia
okay and their first project was to kill
fidel castro or that i don't know that
that was that was a major problem that
was a major project
both these cuban exiles who would
presumably help do it plus organized
crime that had its connections in cuba
as well as its professionals to do
something like that was this just the
umbrella is that term again the umbrella
organization the cia for worldwide
assassinations well it's obviously that
because this this was not just localized
to cuba but it was made applicable
according to a document made applicable
to cuba in 1961
which meant that they were going after
fidel castro
what
one of the strange coincidence i know i
don't call it a coincidence except in a
somewhat of a jocular manner because i'm
up to my eyeballs and coincidences in
this case
this qj win plays an important role in
the release on
very shortly after this assassination of
a man by the name of tom davis released
released from custody of the of the
police over in algeria he was arrested
and as gun running activities
you remember they were having
big warfare and around algeria
in those years
and
so he was released with the
on the behest or with the help of qj win
what makes this intriguing is that tom
davis told a well-respected reporter in
dallas
that he was using the name of oswald
and
in his gun running activities to the
cuban exiles that he was connected to
the cuban exiles but that he was running
these guns with a man by the name of
jack ruby
who was the killer of lee harvey oswald
which as we now know
will be out a shot of a doubt that jack
ruby connects to organized crime
directly so you you see we've come
pretty well full circle
with these with these connections
and jack ruby's
before his trial for the murder of lee
harvey oswald his attorney asked him
if there was anything he didn't want
brought out in this trial
and the one thing that he told his
attorney not to not he'd get anywhere
close to
was tommy davis let's go into this for a
little bit because this is the
hypothesis of the other oswald this is
the book by richard popkin who's a
kennedy assassination expert the thesis
here is that oswald alone couldn't have
done the assassination because there was
more than one rifle we didn't mention in
the first program the rifle that oswald
used was a quite inferior one it's
unlikely that it could perform such a
precision feat of killing the president
from the distance in which he was placed
in relation to the motorcade plus
there's all these other
stories about oswald that would indicate
that he is an unlikely candidate for the
lone assassin and in particular a lot of
pictures of him appeared in different
places holding guns making threats
against the president so that it's
possible that someone was masquerading
as oswald to call attention to him to
set him up as a patsy and so now you're
saying we have a possibility for the
other oswald which is
tom davis all of which would entail a
rather large conspiracy that a lot of
individuals were involved in carefully
planning this operation which require
the sort of apparatus that someone like
the cia or organized crime or a very
well financed and well organized group
would have at their disposal at their
disposal i think very difficult
now
oswald or quote oswald unquote was also
seen in mexico city too
uh in a soviet embassy yeah the soviet
embassy part of this business to blame
it on the comics now did this davis look
like oswald
he had the same build the only
photographs that i have of him there's
no
real strong facial resemblance
but he could comb his hair slightly
different
color it
and his physical makeup was very much
the same
and
all we know is that he said that he was
using that name and that he was in and
around dallas
and
i think probably more importantly
he was traveling across the united
states and he had been with the cuban
exiles and there was reports from cuban
exiles that hey we know roswell and yet
we've had no real reports of oswald
himself having
real close contact with the cuban exiles
did so did any of these other cuban
exiles appear in dallas or is there any
evidence linking specific members of the
cuban exile community that were involved
in this anti-castro activity to the
assassination
well one of the
major
connections would have to be
one that was brought out
probably in about 1976
75
right before i wrote
or right after i wrote the major portion
of cover-up and it was all ready to
press
and that was that a cuban exile who was
involved in attempts to assassinate
um fidel castro
said that he was called by his case
officer his cia contact
to meet him in dallas at a tall building
and when he arrived for that meeting
the cia case officer
was talking with lee oswald
and of course that
case officer has never been completely
identified
but it's it's a good possibility that he
would be
you know a high
ranking member of the cia who was
involved in the planning of the of the
assassination apparatus
and
knew this odds were well now whether
this was highly osmo the one who died on
november
24th 1963 or whether it's this other
oswald what happened to him
tommy davis the second oswald as i call
him he was
they found him
dead up near jacksonville texas at an
old mining
rock mining place
and
allegedly there was no autopsy so we
really don't know much about it but he
had been dead for many days in hot humid
weather
and
he allegedly
was stealing copper from this old mine
to get some money that's how far he had
gone
and cut through
an electrical wire that electrocuted him
but again we don't one of many people
involved with this that died well again
and it happens at strategic times it
happened you know as the senate select
committee had began to investigate this
assassination
of foreign leaders like fidel castro
and he would have been one that would
definitely have been called because of
his connections to qj win a very curious
phenomenon has emerged just this last
week or two and that is that supposedly
the cia was keeping their eye on the
cuban exile community after the kennedy
assassination because they were afraid
that something would be revealed in this
community that might get out to the
press at large and a report says that a
cia officer mr george bush and i think
1963
gave a report to i think j edgar hoover
and the fbi concerning this community
which would indicate that the cia was
intensely involved in what the cubans
were up to and this raises some
questions about mr george bush
who is running for president of the
united states now because he had denied
previously that he was in the cia until
he was named director of the cia in
1975. was this something of a surprise
to you very much you're doing your
research and what did you make of this i
can't make anything out of it right now
except i'm going to look into it more
and more
i'm interested in his connection to a
man by the name of
felix rodriguez
who
is goes back all the way to the bay of
pigs
you know which may or may not mean that
george bush goes all the way back to the
bay of pigs and his involvement with the
cia remember the cia has employees and
then they have contract agents that are
that are hired for specific
tasks and
are really not considered on the payroll
but a paid contract amount and so
they're also denying denying mr bush
denying that he was ever
involved with the cia
prior to 1975 is a little strong i think
on his part right the other thing they
have are assets which are people that
work with them on specific projects an
article just appeared in the middle of
july in the nation magazine that
indicate that george bush's biography
and the stories about him from various
reporters are always very sketchy about
what he was doing in the early 1960s he
was working with his oil business there
that was very active in the caribbean
and he was traveling a lot in that
area which would make him a perfect cia
asset that is someone who would do
activities for them provide information
to them once in a while and have close
working relations with the cia
the bush camp has denied by the way that
he was a member of the cia at that time
and raised the question was there
another mr george bush and this
document it's an fbi document
that
names george bush did tom davis look
like george bush
this could be a major embarrassment for
bush particularly because this felix
rodriguez that you mentioned
turns up in the iran contra operation as
the man in el salvador who was in charge
of getting supplies to the countries and
when the congressional funding of this
project was ended for a couple years mr
rodriguez allegedly engaged in some
illegal activities to get
guns and
different supplies to the countries that
might even involve drug running these
are the allegations yeah they're saying
that that are made and that george
bush's office was in close contact with
felix rodriguez at this time don gregg
who was bush's deputy director of the
cia when he was head of it in 1975 and
who was one of bush's
closest workers in hint bush's office
was in close contact with philip felix
rodriguez in this country
supply operation that would push bush
very close to some highly illegal
operations now if he goes all the way
back to the 1960s
connected with this group this is
sensational
the only thing that i can say is
is i'll
guarantee it won't lay dormant there'll
be some people working on on this
between now and
election time there's another new bit of
evidence that has come up since our
program in 79 and that concerns a
frenchman by the name of swetra
can you tell us about that yeah that's a
an intriguing story and one that we had
just started following
when i was with you back in the in the
late 1970s
we had gotten hold of a cia document
under the freedom of information act
that said that a man by the name of john
swetra a frenchman
also known as michael mertz also known
as michael roo
was
in dallas on the day of the
assassination and was expelled from the
country within 48 hours of the
president's death
and that he had previously been involved
in attempts
on the life of french premier charles de
gaulle
so of course immediately the the antenna
goes up on a document like that here's
an assassin in dallas and nobody's
looking at him so we begin to pursue him
uh
it's been a long trail and we're still
not through but
i can tell you this that there is
actually a jean swetra our people has
talked to him he's denied that he was in
dallas
and in fact he's denied that he's been
in the united states and we have no
proof that he has
there is actually a michael roo
he was
in texas
on the
at the time of the assassination
but the man that we became more
interested in because i traced down the
immigration and naturalization
investigator who was given the
responsibility of going and picking up
that frenchman in dallas on the day of
the assassination and seeing that he was
expelled from the country
and i questioned him about his you know
the identification
and the appearance
the physical description of the man that
he arrested
he said it was a man approximately 45
years old
thinning gray hair
about 200 pounds
well
john sutra was 35 years old in 1963
and a full head of hair
and probably not over 180 pounds
michael rue was only 25 years old
so the only man that met the description
it was with michael meretz
and swetra said told our people that mr
merits used his name quite frequently in
his travels because what mr meretz did
best among other things
was smuggle heroin into the united
states he was a a killer and known as
one
all the way back to the time of world
war ii he became a member of the french
secret service and that's
the equivalent of our cia stack and
in his connections with that
organization
began a drug operation into this country
became very very wealthy not only did he
do that he married
the the daughter of the biggest brothel
owner in paris france now the cia or the
oss at the time was very instrumental in
bringing the
french mafia back and busting heads to
keep the communist unions from
and the communist party from gaining
power in france and they help
particularly in marseilla to help
re-establish the mafia and their drug
operations now is this where this fellow
was connected
this fellow here is connected with that
same group in marseille and how does he
connect with that structure that you
outlined
that might well have been the group that
carried out the kennedy assassination
let us see fit into this scenario that's
what i'm that's what i would like to
know we've not been able to contact him
he's highly protected
lives on a huge
piece of property outside of paris
he is very very wealthy and very well
protected you can't get to him
so
i'd like to ask him
were you in dallas
you know
probably if if i were guessing and
because of his background
he was by the way involved in
infiltrating the oss i mean the oas the
secret army organization that was trying
to kill
president de gaulle right his modus
operandi
to infiltrate the oas
was the same one that oswald used in new
orleans
to infiltrate the pro castro
or make them
right he passed out leaflets right so he
in my opinion is a is a good suspect for
the director of the
assassination and could possibly be qj
win who was a european
he could have
that's an interesting hypothesis he
could have also simply allied himself
with the american mafia to help finance
the operation that would involve a lot
of money and perhaps to provide
personnel for the operation it might be
the french and american mafia got
together and had these intelligence
agency contacts that they'd worked with
and that was the core organization so
this this could easily be a piece of the
puzzle right but we do know that
he was considered the protege of a man
by the name of lucian rivard who was a
french canadian out of the montreal area
who also was in and out of cuba with
santos trafficati
and so the cuban connection comes so he
has the cuban motive as well
right
interesting now we've had
first the warren commission and we had
this most recent
congressional investigation
and we still are involved in trying to
find out what happened
is it just so complex that it's just
impossible to get a handle on or could
it be solved very easily you think i
don't think it's so complex i think it's
just been so
mismanaged
it's the investigation the investigation
a political assassination should never
be
investigated by
political people or in the political
arena in my opinion
if you want to find out who committed
the murder
you get
investigators and people who are
familiar with how to investigate a
murder
and you pay them and you go after it
it's my contention that this case is
is solvable
and
would could be done within probably six
months time
and how would this happen what would be
necessary to carry the investigation the
stage further
i think that
number one it ought to be done in texas
ought to be done in dallas texas well to
convene a grand jury we now have a new
district attorney in dallas who was not
present
at the time of the assassination
and show them the evidence let them
call the people the witnesses subpoena
the evidence
hire the necessary consultants and and
you know i'm not patent myself or any
other critic on the back when i say this
but we've spent 25 years looking at this
we know where the evidence is we know
the places to look
and if there was a mistake that the
house select committee made it was not
taking advantage
of those 20 years
or so of research and experience did
they call any of the people who only had
a
very
you know small
you know and opportune times and it was
never a give and take they never took us
into confidence where
they
if they could tell us something then we
could tell them something it was never
a two-way street and
so they lost a great deal even though we
kept on assisting them right up to the
end with with the questions they would
ask we'd give them the best answers but
had they been able to say well
such and such happened you know and this
this says this
we probably could have taken it a step
further have you been able to get any
assistance or cooperation with any
government agencies or individuals
within them or do you have to wait until
these people retire
i think
no we've not gotten any
probably the most helpful has been the
fbi in the last few years well that's a
change
in the release of documents freedom of
information freedom of information
they've been forced to do it well
they're not as much forced to do it now
as
they
they really do
seem to go out of the way to cooperate
they that's a change yeah a big change
the cia is still a closed door
and
they they won't respond to most anything
and
i think you know basically what must
happen
is that it has to come from the people
again and the pressure has to be put
on
the people in places of responsibility
that can only come by education and the
media too has a responsibility obviously
as we indicated in the first show the
media was part of the cover-up
and it's the media that would focus
attention on this to make it a
worthwhile issue
in terms of putting
importance on it right
you state you talked about in the uh in
the first segment of this
show about the our assassination
archives and research center
and uh our
trust the assassination archive and
research center in washington d.c that
you're a founder and a board of director
that's right okay and our
thrust is going to be not only the
gathering of information and the
gathering of files and the filing of
of information lawsuits when necessary
but also to see that
this is brought to the attention of the
american public
it would be great
if our group which is recognized
academically
as a historical group now
could have prime time television
coverage
and let us just go on the air for a
mini-series if you want to call it
because as you can see by our time
together you can't do it in an hour or
two hours
and show the american people the
evidence
of the conspiracy of the cover-up
of
the potential suspects or
the guilty party
and force
a not necessarily a new investigation a
grand jury
looking into it looking at the facts and
then bringing to trial those that they
feel need to be indicted so you want to
go more through the legal system you've
seen two political investigations
correct that were cover-ups correct so
you no longer think that the federal
government has any interest or
motivation it's not no longer i
predicted it before i said when the
congressional committee was organized
that it should never be in it right so
we shouldn't make this the demand for
the duke if we want to vote for him
that's right because they would just
cover it up anyway even if they did
another investigation but you think if
we got some legal
prosecutions going that this might
unearth the evidence and if the media
took this up and the american people
became educated as to what happened this
could finally solve the case i think it
could i think that we have open-minded
young vigorous attorneys
now with sharp minds
and would have an open mind
to it i'm 50 years old it's been 20 25
years we can furnish them with the facts
and
they're not politically
married yet
and
i think they could do something
now your book cover up
you had to publish that yourself i
understand because you couldn't find a
publisher that would take it
and so there was a kind of limited
edition about three thousand something
like that
is there any way anybody can find copy
of that anymore
every time we play every time we play
your program people call say i want to
buy pub cover up and i can't find it
unfortunately it's out of print and
cannot be found except
occasionally in a used bookstore
are collector bookstores they're selling
collector book stores now for 35 30 35
hopefully
that before too long i'm going to update
it it's 10 years old now or more 12
years old
update it and hopefully find a publisher
this time it's a different mentality
now than it was even in 1976 and
certainly different from the one in 63.
so there's a lot of new evidence and
a lot of directions that we can point
now and i'd like to see it in print
and that brings us to the end of another
alternative use
very glad you could join us
if you'd like to contact gary shaw
his address is po box 722
cleburne texas
76031
that's po box 722 cleburne texas six
zero three one
the organization which gary shaw is
co-founder and member is assassination
archives and research center
in washington d.c
the address is 918 f street northwest
suite 510
and the zip code is two zero zero zero
four
their phone number is area code 202
393-1917
the assassination archives and research
center is set up to
be a repository of all sorts of
materials concerning all assassinations
they have thousands of books articles
manuscripts photos
files tapes they have a computerized
index of fifteen thousand names and
events
and fbi and cia documents
a wonderful organization we'd like to
thank our crew for the program our
director brian lynch camera people
joanna mahalik and beverly garrett
our audio person was robert rober
editing assistance was provided by anna
quatrochi and johanna mahalik
alternative views is a presentation of
the alternative information network p.o
box 7279 austin texas 78713
so long as you're jotting down all these
addresses you might as well jot down
ours
that's
alternative information network po box
7279
austin texas 78713
goodbye